STARTED THAT WE HAVE TO BILLS ON
THE AGENDA --
WE HAVE MR TANGO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SO WITH THAT PLEASE SESAC.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A. B.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY HELPS RENTAL
CAR COMPANIES RECOVER STOLEN
VEHICLES BY SHORTENING THE
WAITING TIME PERIOD TO TURN ON
THE GPS.
FROM SEVEN TO THREE DAYS
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE ADDED
FURTHER --
FOR THE WRITER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND ALSO SUNSETS THE
BILL BY JANUARY FIRST --
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL
CAME ABOUT BECAUSE IN FEBRUARY A
SAN FRANCISCO ARE RENTAL VAN
COMPANY IDAHO QUALITY VEHICLE
AND THIS IS A WAY THAT THEY
COULD OBTAIN ASSISTANCE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH WE WERE ABLE
TO IN THE PAST.
VERY GOOD WITHOUT RESPECT FOR US
ROB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AWARENESS IS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
PEOPLE OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING AND OUR
QUESTION COMMENTS.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WILLA.
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
I DON'T.
THINK WE'VE GOT A SECRETARY.
OUR LEAD US ALL A CALL IF YOU'RE
A HOW KALRA [inaudible]
IN FACT.
WHY SHOULD I I DON'T KNOW IF I
SHOULD DO THAT JUST HOLD ON
INTIMATE LOOK WITH THE?
WHEN SHE GETS HERE THANKS
?
WHY DON'T WE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM BEFORE MISTER COLLEAGUES
AROUND?
THEY'RE RIGHT AMEND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE HOOK CALL THE
ROLL.
CHAO HERE HIGHLY [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN HERE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PRESS.
WE HAVE QUORUM. TO MOVE MISTER
TINGS BILL AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ALL THE
BILL WE HAD JUST HEARD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CHAO.
I SHALL I KILEY.
KILEY AYE BAKER.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE RAYOS.
THE BILL IS OUT. SEVEN TWO ZERO
AND THE ONLY REMAINING BILL IS
SP FOUR SIXTY I UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHOR IS ON HIS WAY.
SO AS SOON AS HE GETS HERE THEN
WE'LL GET STARTED
IT WILL BERMAN
CALDERON AND SHALL AND HAS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL WELCOME MR DE LEóN --
YOU HAVE --
SP FOUR SIXTY BEFORE YOU START
I'D LIKE --
TO TAKE CARE OF A COUPLE OF
HOUSE --
KEEPING ITEMS --
WILL BE LIMITING TESTIMONY ON
THIS BILL TO TEN MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE NOT INCLUDING THE
AUTHOR'S PRESENTATION AND EACH
SIDE MAY DIVIDE THAT TIME UP
HOWEVER THEY SEE FIT
[inaudible]
AND AFTER THE PRIMARY SUPPORT
TESTIMONY PERIOD THE COMEDIAN
WILL CALL UP ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS TO AFTER NAME.
AFFILIATION OF ANY AND POSITION
TO THE RECORD.
ARE LIKEWISE AFTER THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY PERIOD
COMMITTEE WILL CALL UP
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TO AT
THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION TO THE
RECORD --
THERE'S A MOCK UP BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO THE MEMBERS ON SP
FOUR SIXTY REFLECTING. TWO
UPDATES TO THE AMENDMENTS IN
THEM ANALYSIS.
FIRST THERE IS A MINOR CHANGE
BEING MADE TO THE WORDING IN THE
AMENDMENT TO THE BE AYE A. S.
DEFINITION. TO FREEZE SHALL NOT
NECESSARILY EXCLUDE QUOTE
UNQUOTE IS BEING CHANGED TO READ
SHALL INCLUDE.
OUR SECOND THERE'S A NEW
AMENDMENT OUT WILL PROVIDE A FEW
NARROW EXCEPTIONS TO THE BILL.
INCLUDING.
ONE WHEN THERE IS ONLY ONE AYE
S. P. ABLE TO ENTER INTO A
SPECIFIC CONTRACT WITH THE STATE
AGENCY.
AND THAT IS A UNABLE TO PROVIDE
ANY OF THE CERTIFICATIONS
REQUIRED. TWO IF THE CONTRACT IS
SO NECESSARY TO RESPOND TO AN
EMERGENCY AS DETERMINED BY THE
STATE AGENCY DOT ENDANGERS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WELFARE OR SAFETY OR THE
CONTRACT IS NECESSARY FOR THE
PROVISION OF ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
AND NO AND SEE THAT COMPLIES
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
SECTION CAPABLE OF RESPONDING TO
THE EMERGENCY IS IMMEDIATELY
AVAILABLE.
AND FINALLY IF THE AGENCY
SPECIFICALLY REQUEST SERVICES
THAT WOULD NOT NOT BE COMPLYING
WITH THE NET NEUTRALITY RULES.
ANOMALY WE DON'T GO TAKE LAST
MINUTE -- A
MAKE LAST MINUTE CHANGES BUT I
GOT OUT OF CNC YESTERDAY SO WE
ARE ABLE TO A DO SO DIESEL
SUPPORT SUPPOSED TO BE A
COMEDIAN AND MEN'S.
SO WITH ACT UP A SENATORS NEARLY
ALL WELCOME TO OUR COMMITTEE --
AND YOU MAY PROCEED ANY TIME YOU
WISH AND UP.
THANK.
YOU MUCH OF THE MISTER
RESEARCHERS WAS MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN --
KILEY -- I
THINK YOU'RE WHICH WE INDULGENCE
IN YOUR IN YOUR PATIENCE ALSO TO
I'M WE'RE TRYING. TO TO LIFT THE
CALL ON THE THIRD READING FOR
ASSEMBLY BILLS THAT WERE STILL A
A TWENTY GET OUT THE FLOOR SO WE
COULD SIT BACK OBVIOUSLY BACK
FOR CONCURRENT SPIKE TO BE SILLY
SIDE.
BUT AGAIN MISTER CHAIR --
MISTER VICE CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I THINK YOU FREE
INDULGENCE WITH UP TO YOU TO
PRESENT A A SUITABLE FOR SIXTY
AYE AS NOTED --
AS UTRICULARIA --
MISTER CHAIR SUGGESTED BY --
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF --
SO WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS WHEN I CAN BE VERY
BRIEF -- TRY
TRUCK IT IF YOU ALL MY COMMENTS
SIX OF THE WE HAD.
SOMEWHAT OF A LINK THE
DISCUSSION --
YESTERDAY I WANNA BE A ONE ON
ONE ON ONE TEST THE PATIENCE I
THERE'D OF THETHE VICE CHAIR
MISTER OBERNOLTE --
OF OF THE COMMITTEE YESTERDAY TO
KNOW HE WENT THROUGH NOT JUST --
SENATE BILL FOUR SIX BUT ALSO A
SENATE BILL --
A TWENTY TWO WHICH WAS THOUGH
THE ONE VERY ROBUST --
DEBATES ARE ON THOSE ISSUES
BUTTA THREE SH SHORT DECADES AGO
MISTER CHAIR OF THE WORLD JUST
DISCOVERING THE INTERNET.
WE HAD NO IDEA JUST HELP
GRAPPLING COMPLETELY IT WOULD
CHANGE OUR LIVES TODAY AS WE
KNOW THE INTERNET IS CRITICAL TO
FREE EXPRESSION FREE SPEECH AS
WELL AS DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHY THE DECISION BY THE
CURRENT -- A
MAKEUP OF THE FCC --
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE CURRENT
OF PRESIDENT DONALD J. TRUMP IS
ON EXPLICABLE WITH REGARDS TO
RESCINDING THE NET NEUTRALITY.
ó RULES OF FOR UNITED STATES --
HAVING IS SORT OF A INDIVIDUAL
STATE APPROACH --
IS -- BUT IT
IS IT IS A TASK AND I WOULD
CONCUR THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT -- BUT
UNLESS WE CAN HAVE A A A
NATIONAL UNIFORM Y. THIS CAN BE
STATUTORY OR THROUGH THE
REGULATORY SIDE THROUGH THE FCC.
I THINK STATES SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA HAS PROVEN TO BE A
LEADER AND INNOVATOR A DISRUPTOR
OF THE STATUS QUO HAS TO
DEMONSTRATE OF THAT LEADERSHIP.
OF FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND HOPEFULLY MOVE TOWARD A
MODEL THAT COULD BE ADOPTED AND
THEREFORE.
THE HOPEFULLY FOR SECURITY
MINISTRATION TO ADOPT UP ONCE
AGAIN THE TWENTY FIFTEEN NET
NEUTRALITY MEASURES --
I SHOULD THAT MEASURES BASIC
RULES OF LUMIA A CUT TO THE
CHASE SENATE BILL[inaudible]
FOUR SIXTY OF THE THE PROVISIONS
THAT THIS MEASURE OR VERY SIMPLE
AND STRAIGHT FORWARD.
OF THE PRESERVES THE HEART OF
THE FCC'S NET NEUTRALITY RULES
OF BRAVES EYES PEACEFUL BLOCKING
THROWING AND MP PARTS RISE ASIAN
THAT IS --
WITHIN SENATE BILL EIGHT TO TWO
BECAUSE WE AS A STATE GOVERNMENT
ARE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WE
SUBCONTRACT --
A WE SHOULD SAY WE WE SIX A
CONTRACTOR TO DO THAT WHETHER
IT'S A CONTROVERSIAL AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE DMB FOR EXAMPLE
WHETHER IT IS OUR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES --
WE HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET --
TO GIVE --
CONSUMERS ACCESS --
DOT CITIZENS ACCESS TO OUR STATE
AGENCIES SO THEREFORE WE
SUBCONTRACT WITH ALL THE
INTERCEPT INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
WITH THIS MEASURE DOES IN SHORT
IS THAT [inaudible]
IF THE I USE PEACE DO NOT COMPLY
WITH THE PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
AS ENVISIONED IN SENATE BILL.
EIGHT TO TWO THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM ENTERING TO ANY TYPE OF
CONTRACTS.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE VARIOUS AGENCIES --
THROUGHOUT --
STATE GOVERNMENT.
OF WHAT THE BILL IS VERY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND TO THE POINT
HE GOES WITH --
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY TWO
IT'S IT'S VERY CLEAR REASONABLE
STANDARDS FOR INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
AND OFFERS IN THIS IS OUR
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH ONLINE
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS CONSUMERS.
NO IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK --
WITH MISTER WEINER I KNOW YOU
MISTER CHAIR --
HAS A YOU HAVE PLAYED IT A HUGE --
ON THE ISSUE OF OF PRIVACY A
INTERNET PRIVACY NO ONE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT TO OPENLY
PUBLICLY THE ROLE THAT YOU HAVE
PLAYED.
A BECAUSE IT IS RECOGNIZED AND
BOTH THE SENATE AS WELL
OBVIOUSLY WITH MANY --
CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUPS --
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE COUNTRY
THAT'S WHAT THE MEASURE DOES.
THEIR FORCIBLY MISS CHERUBS
VISSCHER ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SENATOR ON
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK AS
WELL AS THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND THEN THROWS.
THE SENATOR ADAM AND ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE TO BRING
THAT NEUTRALITY BOX CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMISSION EXPLAINS.
I LOVE HOW ANOTHER ROUND WITH
THE WHITE MAN GROUP REPRESENTING
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT.
BRIAN BLAKELEY UP BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANKS PLACE.
AND ABOUT CAN BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MUCH.
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME ON UP
.
WELCOME ANYTIME YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S
NICE TO BE BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
A MY NAME IS BILL DIVINE I
REPRESENT EIGHTEEN TAPE.
I LET ME START BY SAYING THAT
EIGHTEEN TIAS ALWAYS SUPPORTED
AND OPEN INTERNET.
OUR COMMITMENTS ARE PUBLISHED ON
OUR WEBSITE THEIR ENFORCEABLE BY
THE STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION AND THE
FCC.
HOWEVER I AM HERE TODAY TO
OPPOSE SP FOUR SIXTY WE BELIEVE
FOR SIXTY IS FAR MORE COMPLEX
THAN JUST PRESENTED.
IT WILL REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES
TO INTERPRET AND ENFORCE THE
CURRENT COMPLEX AND CONFUSING
PROVISIONS IN SB A TWENTY TWO
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT ARE NOT CONSISTENT NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OBAMA FCC NET NEUTRALITY
ORDER.
JUST FIFTY EIGHT DAYS AGO THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD SP A TWENTY TWO
AND PROPOSED A SOLUTION TO THIS
PARTICULAR CONCERN.
THIS WAS ADDRESSED IN YOUR JUNE
TWENTY SIXTH ANALYSIS WHICH ON
PAGE ELEVEN STATED QUOTE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE DEBATE ASIDE
THERE APPEARS TO BE A RELATIVELY
EASY SOLUTION TO RESOLVE THE
MATTER.
THE ANALYSIS CONTINUE THE AUTHOR
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER AN
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD REMOVE ALL
ROOM FOR DEBATE IN THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND THE COMMITTEE OFFERED
LANGUAGE TO THAT EFFECT THAT WAS
DECLINED BY THE AUTHOR OF BOTH A
TWENTY TWO AS WELL AS FOR SIXTY
WE BELIEVE ADDING.
OTHER REQUIREMENT TO DO THE
OBAMA ORDER --
IS THE BEST APPROACH EIGHT
TWENTY TWO IS FLAWED LANGUAGE
AND UNDERSTAND S. B..
FOR SIXTY IS LINKED DIRECTLY.
TO EIGHT TWENTY TWO THE AGENCY
CANNOT -- A
THE AGENCY CANNOT --
OF OR MUST ABIDE BY NET
NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES BUT AS ARE
SPELLED OUT IN SB.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO FORCING STATE
AGENCIES TO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BILL IS BOTH UNTESTED.
UNPRECEDENTED WE THINK IT'LL
CREATE DELAY.
AND CONFUSION CUT DURING THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WE ALSO
THINK SKILL I'D SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPENSE TO THE AGENCIES WHO WILL
NOW HAVE TO DEVELOP EXPERTISE ON
THE SUBJECT OF NET NEUTRALITY.
AS WELL AS MONITOR AND ENFORCE
BEHAVIORS AS COMPLAINTS MAY
ARISE IT WILL ALSO CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE PROTEST.
IN THE STATE PROCUREMENT PROCESS.
NOW YOU WOULD RECOMMENDED AN
AMENDMENT AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO STAFF
BRIEFLY IN THE HALLWAY ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS THERE'S A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE ISSUE
ACCEPTED BROADBAND INTERNET
ACCESS SERVICES SHALL NOT
NECESSARILY EXCLUDE ENTERPRISE
SERVICE OFFERINGS AS DEFINED IN
THAT SECTION.
ENTERPRISE SERVICE OFFERINGS
FREQUENTLY ARE CUSTOM DESIGNED
PROGRAMS OR SERVICES FOR BOTH
STATE GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
THEY ARE THINGS WHERE THE
CUSTOMER AND THE A COMPANY
PROVIDING THE SERVICE CUSTOMIZE.
A SERVICE FOR THE BENEFIT OF
THAT CUSTOMER --
THAT WAS EXCLUDED FROM THE OBAMA
ORDER IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN IT IS ALSO EXCLUDED.
FROM THE OF OUR S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO TWO SENATOR WIENER
EXCLUDED ENTERPRISE SERVICES WHY
DO WE CARE.
FREQUENTLY AND AGENCY WILL ASK
FOR A CUSTOMIZED SERVICE ADDED
ON TO WHATEVER THEIR PURCHASING
IT MIGHT BE FOR EXAMPLE THEY MAY
WANT TO BLOCK.
EMPLOYEES FROM BEING ABLE TO GO
TO ENTERTAINMENT SERVICES ON A
STATE WEBSITE ON THE JOB.
ITS A SIMPLE WAY TO ENHANCE
EFFICIENCIES STATES MANY TIMES
WILL BY THOSE TYPES OF SERVICES
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
VENDOR TO BUILD INTO THE PROGRAM.
BLOCKING.
THING THAT THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT SO IT'S A SMALL NEW
WANTS BUT WHAT YOU MIGHT BE
DOING.
IS ELIMINATING THE KIND OF
CUSTOM FEATURES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DESIGNED TO BENEFIT THE
STATE AND INCREASE EFFICIENCY.
NOW THERE MAY BE OTHER THINGS
THAT FIT INTO THAT CATEGORY THAT
I HAVE NOT HAD THE TIME TO
RESEARCH BECAUSE WE JUST GOT
YOUR ANALYSIS.
BUT WE WOULD BE CAUTIOUS HERE
AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT TO
BE WITHDRAWN AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE WILL ALIGN THE FIRST PART OF
OUR COMMENTS WITH THAT THOSE OF
EIGHTEEN T..
I WOULD HOWEVER I'D LIKE TO ADD
THAT GIVEN THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN AS BEFORE SIXTY AN S. B..
EIGHT TWO TWO EIGHT TWO TWO OF
COURSE WE BELIEVE IS PREEMPTED
WE ALSO BELIEVE FOR SIXTY WOOD
AND ALSO BE PREEMPTED GIVEN ITS
RELIANCE ON THE AND PROVISIONS
OF SB.
EIGHT TO TO THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT HAS IN FACT I HAVE RULED
THAT YOU MAY NOT AND LET.
TO REGULATE DIRECTLY WHAT YOU
ARE NOT AUTHORIZED TO REGULATE
AND DIRECTLY.
INDIRECTLY.
I DON'T THINK I'M SORRY LET ME
REPEAT THAT.
THE US SUPREME COURT HAS IN FACT
RULED THAT YOU MAY NOT REGULATE
INDIRECTLY WHAT YOU ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO REGULATE DIRECTLY
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE PREEMPTED IN
THIS SPACE SOUTH SOUTH.
AND BUT IF I COULD ASK FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION --
MISTER DEVINE SPOKE ABOUT THE
AMENDMENT THAT SUGGESTED ANY
ANALYSIS WE WERE TALKING BRIEFLY
ABOUT ANOTHER SET OF POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M NOT SURE
WHERE WE ARE IF THOSE WERE.
ADOPTED INTO THE BILL.
YEAH I BELIEVE THERE'S A OUR
COPY OF THE MOCK UP THAT'S BEING
CIRCULATED THERE.
ARE THE CONTENT OF WHICH I READ
OFTEN AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR HEARING.
AND IN FACT --
IF I COULD JUST --
TO IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A COPY OF
THAT AS WELL.
DO YOU HAVE IT IN AND OUT.
IN FACT ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
ITEMS SO THAT'S IT CONTAINING
THE MARKUP.
ADDRESSES SO ONE WOULD ONE OF
THE ISSUES RAISED BY MISTER
DEVINE EARLIER TO AND THAT'S OF
RESPECT TO THE ENTERPRISE
SERVICE OFFERING.
ARM SO THAT --
ADDRESSED UNDER ON SECTION TO BE.
THREE SUB THREE SET A WHICH SAYS
IF THE AGENCY SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRE SERVICES THAT WOULD NOT
BE COMPLAIN WITH SUB SECTIONS
SUBDIVISION A TO OUR AND SO
WITHOUT THAT YOU MAY CONTINUE
WHAT WILL IT JUST A LITTLE BIT.
MORE LATER.
TO THE AYE I SIMPLY WANT TO
CLARIFY WHETHER OR NOT THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN ACT ADOPT A
HAVE BEEN LIKE --
DOT TODAY HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED BY
IDEA ABOUT THE AUTHOR CORRECT
THINKING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON TO CTIA FOR WIRELESS A
TRADE ASSOCIATION --
LIKE TO ADD THAT --
IN IN THE PRESENTATION TO TALK
ABOUT ANOTHER HOLIDAY BEING A
BLOCKING THROTTLING AND PAID
PRIORITIZATION.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY ARE THE THREE
PILLARS OF THE OBAMA TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER ON S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO GOES MILES BEYOND
THAT.
DEALS WITH ISSUES LIKE ZERO
RATING INTERCONNECTION AND NOW.
WE ARE ADDING ANOTHER L. TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER AND EFFECTIVE
PROCUREMENT.
SO THESE ARE THREE ELEMENTS THAT
GO AGAIN WELL BEYOND.
WHAT OF THIS COMMITTEE?
THE INDOOR STE --
DE BACK IN THAT BACK IN JULY AND
AND AND SINCE THESE TWO BILLS
ARE.
PART INEXTRICABLY CONNECTED BUT
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN WE
DO ALSO THINK THAT THE BIG.
BECAUSE OF GREAT CONFUSION.
HAVE SITUATIONS WHERE STATE
AGENCIES WHO ARE.
CERTAINLY NOT AN EXPERT IN WHAT
IS NET NEUTRALITY WHAT IS
NETWORK YOU KNOW HOW THE
NETWORKS WORK.
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER
YOU KNOW COMPANY A MAY OR MAY
NOT BE.
A COMPLY BUT THAT TO TRAVEL THE
RULES OR OR COMPANY BE MAY OR
MAY NOT BE COMPLY BUT THAT DO TO
YOU CHARLIE ROSE SO WE THINK
THAT.
YOU KNOW THE VAN DOOR THEN THE
RELATIONSHIP AND IN CALIFORNIA
CAN BE YEAH SIGNIFICANTLY AND
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED YET IN THAT
RESPECT SO.
UP BEFORE OUT FOR THOSE REASONS
WE WOULD RECOMMEND NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESULT BE BRIEF MY
NAME'S JOHN DORY I'M TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SOCIO XIN OF CALIFORNIA --
WE THINK THAT --
THE STATE DECIDING.
THE TYPE.
PROGRAM THEY WANT TO HAVE.
APPROPRIATE --
POLICY DECISION.
BUT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
OF THE LINKAGE TO EIGHT TWO TWO
WHICH HAS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION.
WHICH ULTIMATELY MEANS IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
COMPLIANCE WITH NET NEUTRALITY
IS -- IT'S
ONE THING TO HAVE THE FCC WHICH
IS A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
GIVING OUT RULES AND REGULATIONS
IT'S ANOTHER TO DEPUTISE.
PRIVATE --
FOR PROFIT LAW FIRMS TO LITIGATE
ON AND DETERMINE WHAT IS
COMPLIANT AND NOT COMPLIANT.
AND WHEN YOU TRY TO THEN MAKE
THE AGENCIES DETERMINE
COMPLIANCE IN THAT --
YOU KNOW CONE OF CONFUSION --
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HELP
THE CONSUMER YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE STATE
TO CONTINUE --
TO NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS AND YOU
WILL YOU MAKE IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PROVIDERS TO FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THERE THE
FOLLOWING THE POLICY WISHES SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF EDITION
AWARENESS IS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF PLEASE --
THE ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SARAH BOOT FROM CAL
CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION IT TOO
MUCH NEXT PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM LOW BROWN
BEHALF OF SPRINT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT PLACE.
HEIDI PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SPACE HARD QUESTION ABOUT
COMCAST OPPOSITION AQ.
ALONG THE BENTSEN ON BEHALF OF
CAL CALM THE RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MUCH NEXT WEEK.
SUSAN PETERSON LIPPER WITH T.
MOBILE ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUT OF ITS WAY
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M MISTER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SENATOR YOU AND I HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL
YESTERDAY.
I I WAS EXCITED TO READ THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU PROPOSED IN
HOPES THAT MAYBE THEY'D
ADDRESSED MY CONCERNS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THEY HAPPEN SO JUST REITERATE
THAT YOU ARE EXCITED YOU WORKS
AND I RENTALS IN MAMMOTH I'VE --
YOU KNOW I'D I'D I QUESTION
WHETHER NOT THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY YOU DID ARGUE
REDUNDANCY.
PAY TWENTY TWO SAYS THAT NO
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER.
MAY OFFER INTERNET SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT COMPLYING
WITH THESE PROVISIONS.
AND YOUR BILL SAYS THAT.
THEY CAN'T OFFER IT TO ANY
GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
AND YOU SPECIFICALLY REFERENCE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY TWO AM
MAKE YOUR BILL CONTINGENT ON THE
ITS ENACTMENT SO IT'S ALMOST AS
IF.
SOMEONE'S GOT A BILL THAT SAYS
NO ONE CAN WEAR A GREEN HAT PARA
WOULD KNOW WHAT TO WEAR A HAT
AND YOU HAVE A BILL THAT SAYS NO
ONE CAN WEAR A GREEN HAT.
AND YOU'RE CLAIMING IT'S A
SEPARATE VILLAGE OF JUST
QUESTIONING THE NEED FOR THE
BILL.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT THIS THIS
MEASURE RIGHT HERE YOU ARE IS
TIED TO A SENATE BILL EIGHT TWO
TWO SYMBOL A TWO TWO HAS BEEN
ACTIVE INTO LAW OBVIOUSLY SIDE.
OF BY THE GOVERNOR IF IN FACT IT
DOES PASS --
THE ASSEMBLY AND COMES BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
NOTE TO THE SENATE.
SUITABLE FOR SIXTY EXCLUSIVE
FOCUS.
HE'S ON STATE AGENCIES ANALYSTS
AGENCIES ALONE.
NOT ON THE INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER --
DOES ARE NOT.
CAPTURED IN THE LARGER.
A TWENTY TWO A DEALING WITH DE
NET NEUTRALITY POLICY DEALING
WITH ROWLING SLOWING DOWN
BLOCKING EXOTICS.
YESTERDAY I WAS WE HAD A DEEP
ROBUST LONG DEBATES ON ON THE
ISSUES I WANT REVISITED AGAIN.
THIS MEASURE HERE FOR SIXTIES
EXCLUSIVE FOCUS IS JUST ON YET
ISPS WHO HAVE.
A CONTRACTS WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IF THEY
DON'T MEET THE NET NEUTRALITY
PRINCIPLES AS YOU CORRECTLY
STATE.
THIS TIED.
TO EIGHT TWENTY TO ADD THAN
THOSE CONTRACTS WILL EITHER BE
PROHIBITED WILL BE TERMINATED
ALTOGETHER.
THAT WILL FUND FALL IN THE GUISE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA WILL MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION OR HIS STAFF WILL
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION IF
THERE'S COMPLIANCE OR NO
COMPLAINTS OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
RIGHT.
IT IS CONTINGENT ON THE
ENACTMENT OF A I TO KNOW FOR
SIXTY OKAY SO --
LUDLUM ASK QUESTION A DIFFERENT
WAY.
SO WOULDN'T AN I SP ALREADY BE
PRESCRIBED.
FROM OFFERING INTERNET SERVICE
IN THE STATE IF THEY DIDN'T
COMPLY WITH A TWENTY TWO I THINK
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT THEY
COULD OFFER INTERNET SERVICE TO
A STATE GOVERNMENT AND NOT
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF A
EIGHT TO TWO WITH INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS.
SO YOU DON'T YOU THINK THAT THEY
WOULD.
THEY CAN DO THAT WITHOUT.
OF BEING NON COMPLIANT WITH A
TWENTY TWO I THINK THAT IS A
POSSIBILITY HAVING WE WIN IS I
KNOW IT'S A PART OF A OF A OF A
LARGER JUST DISCUSSION DEBATE
WITH REGARDS TO ONE OF THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND THE I WANT TO SAY THAT THE
ACCUSATION OR THE
CHARACTERIZATION OF THROTTLING --
WITH IN THIS CASE SANTA CLARA
FIREFIGHTERS --
IN THE MENTAL --
MEDICINE A LAKE --
KOMPLEKS FIRE IN LAKE COUNTY NOW
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE OF INTO
INTERPRETATION.
OF WHETHER IT WAS A CUSTOMER
SERVICE ISSUE OR IF THIS WAS IN
FACT THROTTLING I CAN SEE.
WITH POSITION.
OF WHAT IT WHAT'S BUT THAT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN IN
THIS WHAT WE WANT TO TRY TO
PREVENT WITH FOUR SIXTY
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND STATE
AGENCIES ARE AND ARE NOT GOING
TO BELABOR THE POINT BUT I I
JUST DON'T SEE.
THE NECESSITY FOR THIS BILL
GIVEN THE FACT THAT EIGHT TWENTY
TO ARE TO EXIST SO RESPECTFULLY
ALL BE IN OPPOSITION.
FULL A TWENTY TWO DOES EXIST IN
PRINCIPLE RIGHT NOW THROUGH THE
THAT THE MEASURE ITSELF IT'S I
COULD FIGHT.
IT SUCKS STATUTORY LAW SURE I'M
AWARE OF THAT BUT IF IT DOES NOT
BECOME LAW THEN THIS BILL IS
ALSO MOOD BECAUSE YOUR BILL IS
CONTINGENT ON THE NET IS GOING
TO HELP YOU OUT SO QUICK.
ALRIGHT.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I BELIEVE THERE WAS THE ISSUE
RAISED REGARDING THE ADDITIONAL
BURDEN THAT SO THE BILL'S GOING.
TO IMPOSE ON STATE AGENCIES ARE.
ON IT IN UNDER THE ARE THE NEW
SET OF AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THAT
ISSUE IS SAID DR STE.
IT TO SOME EXTENT BECAUSE
INSTEAD OF HAVING THE STATE
AGENCY DO AND DOING THE
CERTIFICATION IT'S THE BURDEN IS
NOW ON THE ISPS.
ARE THAT ARE REQUIRED TO SELF
CERTIFY BEFORE THE GET TO BE
SELECTED BY THIS I THINK IN IN
MANY WAYS THAT KINDA MEDICAID
SEE THE BURDEN SO SPEAKER ON ON
THE PART OF THE AGENCY.
IF IT'S A QUESTION OF FAITH AND
TRUST WITH A SELF CERTIFICATION
PROCESS [inaudible]
YOU'RE CORRECT.
SO IT ON THE INTERNET.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OVER OR QUESTIONS I'M
GOING HOUSE TO SENATOR TO CLOSE
CHIU MAJA I'LL TAKE THAT AS MY
CLOTHES THANK YOU MUCH.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THEM.
OUT WE ARE.
SEE THE MATTER WAS MOVED TO HAVE
A SECOND ON THAT MOTION ESOS
MADE OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAO
AYE AYE CHOW AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
CAROL I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARRESTS. FORTY TWO
SO FAR WILL LEAD TO ROLL WITH
FOUR EPS ADVISER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY MULLIN
[inaudible]
MULLIN I BRASS [inaudible]
REYES I S. B. FOR SIXTY DELEON
[inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RADIUS [inaudible]
RACE I WE GET.
THE TWO SO THAT'S ON FOR SIXTY
TELL ME ANNOUNCES.
THAT THE OTHER ONE WAS SO
UNANIMOUS [inaudible]
TAX.
HEALTH OKAY SO. NINE ZERO
CHOICES.
MS BAKER SO COMING BACK.
I THINK YOU.
THE CARRIER GRADE RIGHT
.
S. B. [inaudible]
FOR SIXTY BERMAN I BERMAN I
HE'S
LIKE YEAH [inaudible] TWENTY
BAKER [inaudible]
BAKER I S. B. FOR SIXTY BAKER.
BAKER NOT VOTING.
SO WHAT'S THE FINAL.
OF THE FINAL VOTE COUNT ON S. B.
FOR SIXTY IS.
SEVEN TWO TWO FINAL VOTE COUNT
ON THE TEN BILL.
IS.
TEN TWO ZERO SO WITH THAT THOUGH
THE MEETINGS ADJOURN